well some breaking news from the last
few minutes the notting hill carnival
which is europe's biggest street
festival has been cancelled organizers
say they cannot put the event on as
normal
due to the ongoing uncertainty and covid
risk it would usually see one million
people
on the streets of west london with a
parade of floats and dancing the events
held entirely outdoors over the august
bank holiday
weekend well joining me now is matthew
phillip he's the director of
the notting hill corner and he joins me
now live from the heart of the carnival
site
matthew very good morning to you this is
obviously going to disappoint
a lot of people why have you made this
decision i mean
the whole event's taking takes place
outside and
30 million of us have had two vaccines
now yeah well the night in hill carnival
is a unique event and
the the information and data available
to us at the moment means that we
we can't be sure that we can put on
carnival in the normal way
um it brings together a lot of people
and
the time it takes to prepare for it you
know we need
certainty the the bands and sound
systems and
the the grassroots people that actually
put on the spectacle that we
know and love every year um have been
very much struggling
um you know it's been difficult for them
to prepare and without you know there's
always ongoing
uncertainty and without a certain go we
you know we we didn't feel it was right
to to
push forward because we need certainty
the bands and sound systems need
certainty
what about uh the police have they put
pressure on you to make this decision
no all of our strategic partners have
been supporting us
in in planning for the streets but you
know the decision was made because you
know we're committed to putting on
a a safe and spectacular carnival and
you know a combination of of risk to
people's health
and and the inability for us to be able
to put it on in the way that it normally
is
is what's led the decision what about
insurance cover was that potentially an
issue that you were concerned about
um that wasn't really an issue for us
because we you know we're not selling
tickets it's a
it's a community event it's free for the
public um
so we you know the cancellation
insurance wouldn't really be something
that we
we would have looked for anyway um it's
it's a free event um
indications were that our insurance
would have been at similar levels to
previous years
now obviously a lot of money is raised
during the carnival for good causes
what is going to happen there i mean are
people still going to be able to make
contributions if they wish
well in the next coming weeks we're
going to be announcing
um a number of smaller events that we'll
be able to do where we can control
numbers
and you know looking at the strategy
behind we need to really
focus on the recovery of carnival and
and the arts
you know like i said before the sound
systems and
masks bands steel bands performers have
really struggled
and we need to refocus our efforts on
coming back stronger
and better in 2022 and that's going to
take a lot of finance um
so you know we will be you know making
every effort to raise as much money to
support those those bands and sound
systems
um as they recover and and come back to
you know this this event in normal times
generates a lot of money for the uk
economy
um unfortunately the the people that put
it on
you know really struggle financially you
know it takes a lot of volunteers and
people put their heart and soul into it
but i think to come back for 2022 we're
going to need um
a big investment to support them so we
can come back
and and be the spectacle that people
know and love